YURI GRINSHTEYN: We try to
automate as much as possible
in our environments,
but we often treat
monitoring as an afterthought.
Today, I'm going to show you how
to get started with automating
the setup of your
monitoring configuration
for a new project
using Terraform.
This is "The Stack Doctor."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's start by
reviewing some basics.
We need to cover
two major things--
what should we automate
when setting up monitoring,
and how we can do that.
Using the Cloud Monitoring API,
we can automate three things--
uptime checks, which are
automated probers that
can let us know if our
service is down or slow,
alerting policies that
create incidents and generate
notifications, and
dashboards that
show us the state and
health of our systems.
Now that we know
what we can automate,
the next question is how.
Here, we also have
three options.
We can use the API directly,
we can use Cloud Deployment
Manager, or we can use
an open-source tool
like Terraform.
Let's take a quick
look at each of those.
Our first option is to use
the API or the gcloud command
to create our entities.
For example, you
can make a call to
the uptimeCheckConfigs.create
method
to create a new uptime check.
You can use the API
Explorer to determine
exactly how to make the call.
Our recommendation would be to
use the API directly only when
no other options are
available, since tools
like Deployment
Manager and Terraform
make this much easier.
Our second option is to use
Cloud Deployment Manager.
It allows you to specify
all the resources needed
for your application in a
declarative format using
YAML files and then
execute them using
the gcloud command-line tool.
You can also use templates to
parameterize the configuration
for better reuse.
Deployment Manager has full
support for Google Cloud
services, and the
state or information
about what's already
been deployed
is stored in the cloud.
Our final option is Terraform.
It's an open-source
product that allows you
to provision resources
across multiple clouds
through the use of providers.
You define the resources you
want to provision in .TF files,
then use the Terraform
command-line tool to validate,
plan, and apply your deployment.
The state is stored locally.
Now that we've outlined
both what we can automate
and what our options
for automation are,
let's take a look at
a specific example.
Today, I want to show you how
to create an uptime check using
Terraform.
You'll need to start by
downloading and installing
Terraform to your workstation.
Note that, if you're using Cloud
Shell, it's installed for you.
You can use terraform
version to confirm.
Next, let's create
our Terraform file.
First, we'll specify
the provider.
We want to use Google, and
we'll provide a default zone
and region for
compute resources.
Next, we're going to define
the resource we're creating.
For our example, we're
creating an HTTPS uptime check
against the root
of the web server
on the standard HTTPS
port, which is 443.
Next, we specify the
monitored resource.
This is where we tell the uptime
check the host we're targeting.
Note that we do not provide
the HTTP or HTTPS here.
We've already specified that.
Finally and optionally, we
can provide a text string.
The uptime check will validate
that the content returned
from the server
includes that string
so that we can check
availability, latency,
and correctness all at once.
We're now ready to
test and run our code.
We're going to use
the Terraform init,
plan, and apply commands to
make sure our code is correct,
see exactly what
it's going to do,
and actually create the check.
First, run terraform init
to install the Google Cloud
provider and initialize your
Terraform configuration.
Make sure you get the
confirmation message
that this step was successful.
Next, run terraform plan
to confirm that the code is
going to do what you expect.
In our case, it should
create a single new resource,
the uptime check we've defined.
Finally, run terraform apply
to actually create the check.
Note that you'll need to
explicitly confirm that you
want to perform this operation.
At the end, confirm
that our operation
created the single new
resource by looking
at the output of the command.
Next, head to the console
to see your uptime
check in the console.
Note that it may take
a few minutes for it
to start running
and returning data.
Let's review what
we covered today.
We learned that cloud
monitoring allows
us to automate the creation
of some common resources using
the monitoring configuration,
like uptime checks,
alerting policies,
and dashboards.
We also reviewed
automation options
and looked at the monitoring
API, Cloud Deployment Manager,
and Terraform.
Finally, we walked
through a specific example
of creating an uptime
check using Terraform.
I hope you've found this
introduction to setting up
automation and treating your
monitoring as code useful.
That's it for this episode.
Come back next time when
we dive into automating
creating dashboards.
This is The Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]